hello you're watching the daily climate
news show on sky news coming up on
today's programme
another rise in gas prices sky news has
learned the government is to propose a
new green tax
the us climate enboy tells sky news that
strange relations between his country
and china are making climate talks more
difficult
and the world's longest undersea cable
brings clean energy from norway to
britain
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
well on the day that the cap on energy
prices increases pushing up costs for
millions of consumers sky news has
learned that the government is also
looking at imposing a new green tax
now the heat and building strategy will
set out how the government will
decarbonize heating systems in homes and
is due to be published in the next few
weeks well let's bring in our deputy
political editor sam coates sam thanks
very much indeed for joining us what
have you learned
so this week we saw gas prices hit an
all-time high but i've seen a copy of
the forthcoming heat and building
strategy which is the government has is
due to publish next month been delayed
uh for more than six months now this
will set out one of the big aims of
government which is to find ways to
encourage people to get rid of their
existing gas boiler gas being less
environmentally friendly and move over
to an electric powered
heat pump now the problem with the
strategy is that electricity at the
moment is three to four times more
expensive than gas so in order to
incentivize people to switch the
government i understand is looking at a
new levy on gas in order to equalize the
prices the strategy document that i've
seen says the price differential between
gas and electricity is a critical
barrier to the decarbonization of heat
and will need to be addressed it is
intended that a levy on gas will be
applied to licensed gas suppliers in
great britain and the costs are expected
to be passed on to gas bill payers the
unenviable choice for ministers is if
they want to equalize the amount that
you pay for gas and electricity you
either put a new levy on gas or the
treasury would have to pay about five
billion pounds a year according to
policy exchange in order to get rid of
the existing top-up tariffs uh on
electricity uh it looks like the
government are leaning towards the
former although no final decisions have
been made government sources stress that
any decision they take will still mean
gas bills are affordable
certainly an uncertain type of consumers
sam thank you
the u.s climate envoy john kerry has
been attending a conference in milan
ahead of the cop 26 climate summit which
starts in glasgow now at the end of this
month we're speaking exclusively to our
climate correspondent hannah thomas
peter he said that strange relations
between the us and china have made it
harder for him to do his job
i'm i'm confident rejoin u.s special
envoy on climate change john kerry in
milan
shuttling between meetings a frantic
diplomatic push just days ahead of a
crucial u.n climate summit in glasgow
known as cop26
his big problem right now is the world's
biggest polluter china
our strained u.s china relations making
it harder for you to do your job
and convince china
to be more ambitious
uh the answer is yes it's been more
complicated because of other issues
climate was going to be treated on its
own
but reality has crept in in the last few
months
and so there's been
a slowdown in our ability to be able to
move what message will it send to the
rest of the world though if president xi
does not turn up to cop 26 in person i
haven't really thought about it very
much to be truthful with you i think 190
some countries will come the vast vast
majority of countries in the world are
very anxious to be part of
a moment where we really turn a corner
as host of cop 26 that includes the uk
although boris johnson did recently
refer to tackling global warming as
bunny hugging and has been criticized
for making big promises that lack detail
do you fully trust
that boris johnson is the right person
to help lead the global fight against
the climate crisis
well the proof is in the pudding right
i've been impressed by the statements
he's made
uh but in the end
um
you know we have to get there and and
it's the doing that's what will
determine
people which should determine
the judgments people will make about
glasgow and what happens there do you
ever feel anger
towards those nations and leaders who
are not willing to act
i feel frustration and for the last 30
years we have known how bad it is i
don't know sometimes i can reserve the
anger and scream
in the dark
but i'm not going to do it publicly
do you view cop 26 perhaps as an
opportunity for redemption
or a generation that failed to tackle
the climate crisis i haven't thought
about it that way no we're a generation
that
marched for civil rights and for human
rights and we made a difference so uh
you know i'm not here to apologize i'm
here to fight for the next step
even with all the remaining challenges
he says he's confident that glasgow will
provide that next step
the science is increasingly clear
our warming planet needs him to be right
thank you hannah thomas peter sky news
in milan
well in some of today's other climate
news 39 people have been arrested after
climate group insulate britain blocked
three motorway junctions this morning
well it's the tenth day of action by the
activists who have pledged to continue
until the government makes a meaningful
statement indicating that they will
insulate all of britain's 29 million
leaky homes by 2030.
the green party has elected carla denyer
and adrian ramsey as its new co-leaders
following the announcement carla denyer
a former bristol city council leader
said it's more vital now than ever that
green policies are adopted for the
benefit of our climate and our
communities and the queen and the prince
of wales have planted a tree at balmoral
castle as part of a special initiative
for her platinum jubilee it marks the
start of the planting season for a
scheme called the queen's green canopy
created to mark her 70 years service to
the nation and urging people to plant a
tree for the jubilee
now we heard earlier about the
government's trying to persuade
consumers to switch from gas to
electricity to power their homes well as
we make that big move away from fossil
fuels to electrification the climate
change committee says the uk's
electricity demand will treble by 2015
so we'll need more sources of clean
electricity
well on our data dashboard we track the
live data of what power the country is
using at any given moment so right now
we can see here that 56
of great
electricity is coming from renewables
and around six percent of that
comes from abroad through undersea power
cables called interconnectors
well a new interconnector the north sea
link that's what it's called it's been
launched today and it's almost entirely
sourced from clean hydro powered
electricity it links northumberland with
norway and from there thomas moore has
this report
norway is one of the world's biggest
producers of oil and gas but it's water
that provides almost all its domestic
power its steep valleys and abundant
rainfall are perfect for hydro
electricity
huge reservoirs feed a network of pipes
and turbines built inside the mountains
producing so much green energy that some
will now be exported to britain through
a cable under the north sea the longest
in the world
when we talk about this project
people in their minds have you know
visualizing a cable or that size you
know but as you say it's not it's it's
about this it's um it's a technology
that's been proven and it works and we
can assure you that the 1.4 million uh
households will get
electricity and it will be hydropower
the cable snakes along valleys in the
west of norway before diving beneath the
waves emerging in blythe northumberland
the hydroelectricity it brings should
reduce the uk's carbon emissions by 23
million tons by 2030.
one of the big challenges in the shift
to renewable energy is the intermittency
of supply sometimes the wind doesn't
blow and the sun doesn't shine but hydro
power could help fill the gap in effect
norway can be a giant battery for the uk
the uk now generates a quarter of its
electricity from wind but an unusually
calm summer at the same time that the
price of gas the usual standby spiked
left the national grid firing up a coal
power station to keep the lights on
as a result of the of this cable and all
of the other cables bills will fall and
that's because in the uk we can access
cheaper energy from the continent and
transport that energy through our
interconnectors um meaning that the
people in the uk are receiving energy
from from cheaper more plentiful sources
of of green electricity across across
continental europe
green energy could in time be exported
to norway as britain's wind capacity
almost doubles over the next decade but
for now much of the electricity will be
coming the other way once again it's
viking power that crosses the north sea
thomas more sky news in kvildale norway
now we've heard about rising gas prices
tensions ahead of cop 26 and our need to
move away from fossil fuels but what
does all this mean for the government's
vision for a greener future well our
science and technology editor tom clark
is here tom good to see you can you pull
all these threads together and help us
understand what it may mean i'll have a
go sally i mean i think if we start with
the the electricity piece
moving away from fossil fuels is going
to drive up our demand for clean
electricity maybe doubling our demand by
about 2050. so we need as much as we can
get thomas's piece there showed one way
of getting it sending it over from
places where there's an excess of
renewable electricity in a way that's
the easy bit far more challenging how do
we get the heat the carbon out of our
heating system and that's the thing that
we heard from sam coates earlier this
night how do you decarbonize the heat in
our buildings especially at a time when
gas prices are just going up and up and
up now in many ways what better time to
try and sell the idea of of net zero to
people when we're becoming increasingly
dependent on these very volatile gas
prices but to other people they might
say how can we possibly afford a levy on
our gas bills when they're just going up
anyway the challenge for the government
persuade consumers of the benefits that
netsu are going to bring for example
insulating your homes will reduce those
bills and those policy levers and how we
get that right is so important because
it's not just uk
bill payers who are looking the world is
watching us as we go to cop if we want
to persuade stand aside john kerry and
persuade the chinese to come along with
us we need to show credible plans for
action not just sort of ambition the
home foundation is now over really
absolutely a lot going on tom thanks for
talking us through it
well stay with us because coming up
after the break i'll be joined by
co-founder of earthrise alice aidy and
new york magazine's editor at large
david wallace wells we'll be discussing
whether individuals should pay to make
their homes greener and if we should
worry about eco anxiety yes it's a thing
we'll be talking about it after this
short break they're standing by do join
us
[Music]
they have breached the road there is
a lot of gas being fired all around us
[Music]
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modi's decisive victory
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
what is shared that over 200 people
might have died because of these
landslides
[Music]
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today it's
absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of northeast delhi where there's been
clashes
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself
which houses frogs snakes crabs turtles
birds so many different life forms
human beings directly depend on
underground water source so a lake or a
pond is necessary to replenish these
groundwater resources
[Music]
did you know that driving us to school
creates extra toxic air at drop-off and
pick-up times
[Music]
it'll be a chilly start to saturday for
many but cloud and rain gathering in the
southwest will push its way north
eastwards through the day to get some
very wet weather for many parts
parts of ireland northwestern scotland
will fare a little better but even here
there'll be some rain and looking at
temperatures reaching a high of 16 or 17
degrees celsius at best that's 63
degrees fahrenheit
however these very unsettled and
blustery conditions do mean the air
quality will remain quite good with
pollution levels being low throughout
the day
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day with the
co-founder of earthrise studios alice
aidy and journalist and best-selling
author david wallis wells a very warm
welcome to you both well we've waited
months for the government's heat and
building strategy it's important because
homes account for around 15
of all of the uk's carbon emissions and
the idea is to incentivize people to
move to electricity by making them pay
more for using gas but will this work
and is it fair who should pay for
greening our homes david to you first
i think we know a few things the first
is that this transition needs to happen
a recent study i saw suggested that
actually twice as much emissions are
coming from home heaters as they're
coming from all of the country's power
missions we know that the country will
be better off and prices will be cheaper
in the medium and long term if we make
this transition and we know to this
point that the prices that we have been
paying don't reflect the true cost of
burning these fuels i think globally the
imf believes that fossil fuels are being
subsidized to the tune of five or six
trillion
dollars every year um to me the answer
is quite clear that the government's
role is to make sure that things that
look appealing and attractive in the
medium and long term can be afforded
today and i think for that reason um
it's the government's role to be sure
now um taxes can play a role there but
i'd like to see the uk government also
doing more subsidy on the uptake and on
the electricity end so that it's not
just a stick approach but also a carrot
approach
so who should be paying for it
governments
consumers or industry alice 28 of
homeowners in the uk don't plan to
eco-upgrade their homes at tax
incentives the answer
i mean look i can i can speak from the
perspective of someone through my work
and in photography and filmmaking who's
been traveling to climate front lines
and i can completely understand for uk
homeowners this issue might feel distant
abstract coming far down the line but we
really
have an incredible amount of evidence
we've had it for decades and if we
needed any more there have been historic
flooding in germany historic wildfires
across california
i i would ask what other choice we have
than to lead this transition and and i
would speak of our sort of massive
responsibility to do so and to do so as
quickly as possible um you know the rate
of our we are in the uk the home of the
industrial revolution we began this sort
of hugely
uh
misguided fossil fuel experiment um and
now i really believe that it's our role
to lead the transition out of it is it
going to be easy to retrofit 29 million
homes
absolutely not um but i would say that
the cost of inaction far outweighs
uh the cost of action and and you know
as as david says and and as he painted
so powerfully in his book this is
literally talking about trillions of
damage if we don't take action
and just briefly david before we move on
how does the u.s compare by comparison
america huge energy consumers but also
huge potential for renewables
well we're not doing nearly as well as
the uk uh we have a much smaller share
of renewable power um but we're on the
brink i hope of making massive
investments here to green our grid um
with the with the infrastructure
reconciliation bills that are being
talked about right now so we're i would
say we're lagging behind um but i i hope
that if we were talking a month from now
the picture would look a lot greener
okay just moving on to our next big
subject of the day a week after prime
minister boris johnson said humanity is
reaching a turning point on climate
change there's been a warning that
people's anxiety levels over the issue
is reaching an all-time high could
scaring people too much
end up preventing them from taking
action
how do we find that balance how should
we deal with climate anxiety alice
well the way we talk about climate is
something i'm i'm very preoccupied with
how do we tell this story and how do we
make people feel um
powerful and and not powerless i'm not
sure i have the answer but should we be
concerned about eco anxiety 100
um and i would say that
feeling anxiety in the face of headlines
like uh you know the ipcc's red code for
humanity scientists telling us untold
suffering is coming down the line if we
don't take action these are entirely
rational responses to the information um
that we are learning i'm hearing about
the rise of climate cafes across the uk
sort of workshop therapy sessions for
for young people and and i i can't help
but think about you know not so long ago
young people when they thought about the
future um it was a future of flying cars
and and now it's
one that is very dystopian but we have
to talk not only about the sacrifice and
not only about the dystopia but also
about the opportunities that we have to
build a better and fairer and greener
world
as you mentioned there alice young
people certainly are the demographic
that are going to have to deal with
climate change for longer and the
demographic that are more concerned
about it 56
of young people according to a recent
poll think humanity is doomed david how
would you reassure them
i think the opportunities are there to
make sure the future is much more
comfortable and much more attractive
than the one they imagine reading the
climate science headlines that's because
dramatic change is quite possible it's
not because the climate science is
um
you know being presented in a too scary
manner that is what the science says we
don't change course we don't take action
the world will not resemble the one that
our parents and grandparents and
great-grandparents lived in um
the
what we would have to do to live
comfortably in that world is far beyond
our imaginations and we have to take
seriously just how urgent the crisis is
if we hope to respond to it for those
who worry about climate anxiety i think
it is real for people who are
preoccupied with the subject but i also
think it is a motivator i think if we
look at the last few years um after the
ipc's 1.5 degree report we saw the rise
of brother tinberg and the um the school
strikers we saw the rise of extinction
rebellion in the u.s we saw the rise of
sunrise and all of global climate
geopolitics has changed in the aftermath
of those protest movements which were
motivated by fear they also offered
positive visions of the future i think
those are important too but they were
driven primarily by anxiety i think we
should respond to how scary the science
is by mobilizing not by um collapsing
into despair but i think we have to take
seriously just how urgent the science
says the matter really is
and alice where would you strike the
balance just briefly before we let you
go
the chair of the climate change
committee said if you scare the if you
scare the public you don't get people to
act do you believe that's true
uh i think that
as david says it's it's a motivating
factor for me action is the antidote to
anxiety so you know many of us may act
from fear um it is
not so productive to act from a place of
fear so how can you transform that
emotion into something productive
be an activist whatever that means to
you it doesn't necessarily mean standing
out on the street in protest um it means
different things to all of us but find
what you're good at find what you can
contribute to the movement and play your
part alice aidy and david wallis wells
thank you both very much indeed for
joining us today